so President Trump talked about all of
this all of the pulling down of statues
a lot of normal people most normal
people opposed this kind of stuff you'll
notice when you look at who was pulling
down the statues it's a lot of people
clad in black they look like they're
part of far left organizations either
BLM which we'll get to in one second or
antifa
or other various anarchist and communist
groups I don't think they speak for most
people actually Muhammad Ali jr. son of
the famous boxer and the civil rights
advocate and social activist he came out
and strongly opposed all the statue
toppling in the riots and the looting
and the protests he said don't use
colorful language which I'll have to
clean up a little bit he goes don't bust
up stuff don't trash the place
you can peacefully protest my father
would have said they ain't nothing but
Devils my father said all lives matter I
don't think he'd agree with the BLM
movement actually Muhammad Ali jr. said
that he thought the BLM movement was
racist and then he went on to defend
cops he said police don't wake up and
think I'm going to kill an n-word today
or kill a white man they're just trying
to make it back home to their family in
one piece obviously correct
Muhammad Ali jr. I have been telling you
this for many weeks now that the black
lives matter organization is a very very
bad organization it is not what it
purports to be it is a radical leftist
anti-american no good very bad
organization and nobody should have
anything to do with it and as a result
of saying that I and others have been
called racist bigoted terrible dishonest
okay well over the weekend the founders
of the black lives matter movement
actually admitted that my take on it is
correct
[Music]